and by the way Twitter's had outages
there's a thing about outage this week
but just remember he is currently
running the current Twitter with
onethird the staff that he did before
and he's building new functionality in
it suffering with some things but what's
going on in the b in the background is a
stronger Twitter is emerging and as soon
as the corner turns on micr
subscriptions because he was charging
people for the blue check and he's going
to be charging people for other things
and he was a destination for things like
uh Tucker Carlson show so there's a lot
happening in the background while the
pressure is on the stock and the
advertisers are away you know what's
going to happen as soon as the
advertisers step back and some of these
other subscriptions go all of a sudden
Elon Musk is going to make an
announcement and a quarterly report just
like he did with Tesla now we moved uh
we sold a lot more cars than you thought
we did remember those announcements come
oh he's got all these trouble and you
know you know full self-driving FSD has
got problems and he comes out well there
may have been problems but we we we sold
30,000 more calls than we thought